Vous pénétrez ici dans l'un
des endroits les plus mystérieux
et les plus méconnus
de toute la Terre.
Nous sommes au fond
de l'océan Atlantique,
dans une
zone géographique
qui a enfiévré l'imagination
de l'Homme depuis des siècles.
Où des bateaux,
des avions et des Hommes
ont disparu sans laisser de
traces et sans raison apparente.
La plupart ont fini ici
dans le silence
et l'obscurité des profondeurs.
Ceux qui connaissent cette région
lui ont donné des noms éloquents,
Le cimetière des égarés,
La mer porte-malheur,
La quatrième dimension.
Mais pour beaucoup de gens,
elle n'a qu'un seul nom
qui intrigue tous ceux
qui en entendent parler.
Ce nom, c'est
le Triangle des Bermudes.
Nous sommes
sur la côte de Floride,
au bord du
Triangle des Bermudes.
Bonsoir,
je suis Richard Crenna.
Plus d'un millier de personnes,
plusieurs centaines de bateaux
et des douzaines d'avions
sont entrés dans le Triangle
et n'en sont
jamais ressortis.
Beaucoup disent avoir
ressenti des forces étranges
qui ont endommagé leurs
bateaux ou leurs avions.
Quelles sont donc
ces forces bizarres
qui ont fait du Triangle des
Bermudes ce cimetière fatal ?
Faut-il croire au mythe
selon lequel les disparus
auraient été enlevés
par des extraterrestres,
transférés dans
un univers parallèle
ou même entraînés
dans un autre espace temps ?
Ou ont-ils
juste été victimes
de phénomènes
naturels extraordinaires,
plus puissants que tout
ce qu'ils auraient pu imaginer ?
Nous allons lever le voile
sur cette région perfide
et vous révéler
certains de ses secrets.
À l'aide d'engins de plongée
à grande profondeur,
nous examinerons des épaves,
ces fantômes des profondeurs
qui jonchent
les fonds marins.
Nous enquêterons sur les cas
les plus déconcertants
de l'histoire
du Triangle des Bermudes.
La légende remonte
à l'époque de Christophe Colomb,
il y a 500 ans.
Le Triangle des Bermudes
couvre plus d'un
million de kilomètres carrés
entre la Floride,
les Bermudes et Porto Rico.
Des incidents inexpliqués
s'y sont produits.
En 1963,
le Marine Sulphur Queen,
un cargo de 130 mètres avec
39 Hommes à son bord, disparaît.
Six mois plus tard,
deux KC-135,
de gros avions ravitailleurs
de l'US Air Force
se volatilisent littéralement.
Un remorqueur,
le Good News,
se voit confronté
à des forces inconnues
alors qu'il tracte une barge
de 2 500 tonnes dans le Triangle.
En 1948, un DC-3
partit de San Juan
à destination de Miami avec
36 personnes à bord disparaît,
alors qu'il venait de recevoir
de la tour de contrôle
les instructions pour se poser
et apercevait déjà la côte.
Et en 1986, un homme et sa femme,
volant dans un petit avion
entre les Bermudes et la Floride,
racontent qu'ils sont entrés
dans une substance
comparable à du lait de poule.
Tous leurs
instruments électroniques,
d'une valeur totale
de 2 millions de dollars,
ont soudain
cessé de fonctionner.
Mais tout de suite,
le plus célèbre de ces mystères.
La disparition de l'escadrille 19,
cinq bombardiers de l'US Navy
avec quatorze hommes
d'équipage, en décembre 1945.
Toutes les réponses sont là,
dans les profondeurs.
Pendant la
Deuxième Guerre mondiale,
l'Avenger passait
pour le meilleur
bombardier
lance-torpilles du monde.
Mais plusieurs Avengers partis
en mission d'entraînement
dans le Triangle des
Bermudes allaient faire date
pour une
toute autre raison.
- Powers, ici Taylor.
Ma boussole
ne fonctionne pas.
Que dit la vôtre ?
- Je n'ai aucune idée
de l'endroit où on est.
On s'est perdus
après ce dernier virage.
- Pour Everglades à FT-28,
lieutenant Taylor
vous nous recevez ?
- Affirmatif. Nous venons
de survoler une petite île.
Nous ne connaissons
pas notre position.
Il semble
que nous soyons perdus.
- Ici pour Everglades.
Je suggère
qu'un autre avion
avec une boussole
qui fonctionne prenne la tête.
- Bien reçu.
C'est vraiment bizarre,
on n'arrive pas à retrouver l'Ouest.
Impossible de s'orienter.
- Si seulement on retrouvait l'Ouest
on pourrait rentrer au bercail.
- On va trop au Nord
au lieu de l'Est.
Il pourrait y avoir n'importe quoi
devant nous on ne verrait rien.
- Escadrille 19 écoutez,
il faudra faire
un amerrissage forcé,
sauf si on peut se poser.
À tous les avions,
restez en formation serrée.
Dès qu'un avion a moins de
40 litres, on tente un amerrissage.
- Un bateau à gauche.
- Mon lieutenant,
je largue le reste des bombes ?
- Oui, allez-y.
- Pour Everglades à FT-28.
Avez-vous reçu
mon dernier message ?
Passez sur
3000 kilos/ cycles.
- On va peut-être devoir
amerrir mon lieutenant.
- On devrait
apercevoir les lumières.
- Pour Everglades
à FT-28 répondez.
Escadrille 19.
- Quatorze hommes de la Navy
volaient dans cinq avions
tels que ceux-ci.
L'Avenger,
un bombardier lance-torpilles.
Le plus gros monomoteur utilisé
pendant la Deuxième Guerre mondiale.
La disparition de l'escadrille 19
le 5 décembre 1945
reste la plus marquante
de toutes les tragédies
du Triangle des Bermudes.
C'est l'une des pires catastrophes
aériennes de l'Histoire.
On lance aussitôt
des recherches en mer,
mais elles restent vaines.
Les familles des disparus
accusent la Navy
de vouloir étouffer l'affaire.
Une commission d'enquête
finit par déclarer
que l'escadrille
a disparu pour causes inconnues.
Cette affaire est décrite
comme la plus étrange
sur laquelle on ait jamais enquêté
dans les annales de l'aéronavale.
On passe au crible
plus de 900 000 kilomètres
carrés d'océan, en vain.
À l'annonce de la catastrophe,
la Navy envoie sur les lieux
un avion de secours
avec treize hommes.
Lui aussi disparaît.
L'instructeur de l'escadrille
était le lieutenant Charles Taylor,
un pilote
de combat expérimenté.
Muté depuis peu
à Fort Lauderdale
il ne connaissait
pas la région.
Le lieutenant Ed Powers
faisait aussi partie de l'escadrille.
Sa femme nous raconte
comment elle a appris
la terrible nouvelle.
- Je me suis réveillée la nuit
où c'est arrivé vers minuit
et j'ai appelé la base parce que
j'avais un mauvais pressentiment.
Ils m'ont dit
qu'Ed n'était pas là,
sans me donner
aucune explication.
Le lendemain, j'ai entendu
à la radio que cinq bombardiers
étaient portés disparus
à la base aéronavale
de Fort Lauderdale
et j'ai tout de suite su
que c'était eux.
- À l'époque, certains
croient que les pilotes
ont été enlevés
par des extraterrestres.
Des années plus tard,
Steven Spielberg
exploitera ce thème
dans son film
Rencontres du troisième type,
dans lequel
on retrouve
les avions
dans le désert mexicain
et les pilotes
dans un vaisseau spatial.
- Je pense que toutes
ces théories sur des ovnis
et des distorsions de l'espace
ne tiennent pas debout.
Mais au début,
quand j'en ai entendu parler,
je m'y suis raccrochée
en me disant que c'était
peut-être ce qui s'était passé
et qu'il y avait peut-être
une chance qu'ils aient survécu.
- Qui aurait cru alors,
qu'un demi-siècle plus tard,
on serait encore à la
recherche de ces cinq Avengers.
Le bateau de
recherche Deep See
s'est lancé dans
une dernière expédition
pour tenter
d'élucider le mystère.
À la tête de l'expédition,
Graham Hawkes,
aventurier et océanographe.
Vétéran en matière de
recherche de l'escadrille 19.
Pour la localiser, il aura fallu
douze ans de recherches à John Myhre,
ancien membre de la Direction
Générale de l'Aviation Civile
et pilote d'hélicoptère
de combat au Vietnam.
- J'ai rassemblé tout ce qui
se rapportait à la navigation.
Je me suis procuré
des cartes de 1945.
J'ai déterminé
ce qui avait changé
et j'ai reproduit ces variations
au demi-degré près.
D'autres gens qui naviguaient
dans ce secteur cette nuit-là
ont raconté qu'ils n'avaient
jamais vu une mer aussi agitée.
Quand le premier
pilote s'est crashé,
Taylor avait dit
une demi-heure plus tôt :
« Quand le premier
gars descendra,
on tentera tous
un amerrissage forcé ».
Et le premier gars a amerri.
- La météo était si mauvaise
qu'ils ont perdu tout contact visuel ?
- Je pense, oui.
- Donc ils n'ont pas
délibérément désobéi aux ordres.
Ils ont perdu le contact
et ça a été chacun pour soi.
- Là, à un moment donné,
suite à une
décision du chef d'escadrille
ou à une
mutinerie des pilotes,
ils ont viré
à 180 degrés à l'Ouest,
ce qu'ils auraient dû faire
depuis le début.
- Mais ils croyaient être
au-dessus du golfe du Mexique
et l'Ouest
est en plein océan.
- Absolument.
- C'est une
erreur plutôt grave.
- Et ça, c'est la première
supposition scientifique.
Là où il y a un petit rond.
Et cet endroit
s'est avéré être
à environ six
kilomètres au Nord
de la position
que j'ai finalement déterminée
qui est ici.
- C'est donc
la version corrigée.
- Exactement.
- Il n'hésite pas à faire une croix
au milieu de l'Océan.
On va
fouiller cette zone.
On est
limités par le temps.
Si les avions sont là,
on les trouvera.
Mais vous savez,
l'Océan est immense.
Franchement, John,
si on les trouve,
je vous tirerai
mon chapeau.
Je le mangerai même.
- J'adorerais voir cela.
- Myhre fonde de grands
espoirs sur ce projet,
car retrouver les Avengers
est devenu une obsession pour lui.
Il a déjà essuyé
des déconvenues.
Cinq ans auparavant,
lors d'une expédition similaire,
il a localisé
l'épave d'un Avenger.
Mais une fois
remontée à la surface,
on s'est aperçu qu'elle
n'appartenait pas à l'escadrille 19.
Graham Hawkes a connu
le même genre de déconvenue
il y a quelques années,
quand il a découvert
un groupe
de cinq Avengers.
Il avait alors déclaré
qu'ils étaient
peut-être de l'escadrille 19,
mais la presse
avait déformé ses propos
et affirmé que les Avengers disparus
avaient enfin été retrouvés.
Deux jours plus tard,
Hawkes avait tenu
une conférence de presse
pour rétablir la vérité.
- Nous sommes au regret
de devoir vous dire
que nous avons
acquis la certitude
que les cinq
avions trouvés
n'appartenaient pas
à l'escadrille 19.
- La recherche des Avengers
n'a donc rien de nouveau
pour ces deux hommes.
Mais pour corser l'affaire,
on sait que près de 150 Avengers
se sont abîmés au large
de la Floride pendant la Guerre.
Pour Graham Hawkes,
la découverte de l'escadrille 19
serait un prélude idéal
à son but ultime,
plonger en solo jusqu'aux
tréfonds de la planète.
Considéré comme l'un des
innovateurs les plus renommés
en matière d'océanologie
et d'exploration sous-marine,
il est un peu
l'Enzo Ferrari de la mer.
Hawkes
dirige le groupe
d'exploration
océanographique de Californie.
Il a dessiné de
nombreux submersibles
et partage
le record mondial
de profondeur
de plongée sous-marine en solo.
Récemment, il a conçu
le Deep Flight 2,
un submersible
ressemblant à un avion
qu'il espère piloter
dans l'endroit le plus
profond de tous les océans,
la fosse des Mariannes.
Le bateau de recherche Deep See
s'est lancé dans une expédition
pour tenter d'élucider
le mystère de l'escadrille 19.
Il transporte
un équipement ultramoderne
de recherche sous-marine,
en particulier
un sonar à balayage latéral
et un véhicule
télécommandé, le ROV.
Tandis que le Deep See explore
la zone cible de recherche,
le responsable du sonar,
Bill Mastrud,
ne quitte pas
des yeux ses écrans.
Soudain,
il repère quelque chose.
- Vous ne croyez pas
que c'est un avion ?
Et bien, j'espère
que vous vous trompez.
- Il est même possible
que ce soit du poisson,
mais ça ressemble quand même
à une cible potentielle.
On va tourner autour pour
tâcher d'en avoir le cœur net.
- Le seul poisson
qu'on ait vu c'est...
Je pense
qu'il se trompe.
C'est un avion.
- Ça pourrait être
n'importe quoi John.
On peut continuer
à s'approcher pour voir.
- Désolé, mais j'ai du mal
à croire que ce n'est pas ça.
- Il s'avère que
ce n'est pas un avion.
La déception de
John Myhre augmente
au fur et à mesure
que les recherches s'intensifient.
- Ça fait douze ans
que je travaille là-dessus
et tout le monde
dit que je suis fou.
La Navy,
les gardes côtes, tous.
Je suis peut-être fou,
mais là, je pense que j'ai raison.
- Les recherches se
poursuivent quand soudain,
une grosse tempête
se met à ballotter le bateau.
L'équipe décide alors
d'abandonner les recherches,
n'ayant trouvé
aucune trace d'épave d'avion.
Le Deep See met le cap vers
le Sud en direction d'un endroit
où Graham Hawkes a la preuve
qu'un avion s'est abîmé en mer,
peut-être un
Avenger de l'escadrille 19.
D'ordinaire, le
Deep See parcourt les mers
à la recherche d'épaves
de galions espagnols
dans le cadre d'un projet
de recherche scientifique.
En cherchant
ces trésors du passé,
l'équipe a découvert
des centaines de bateaux
et d'avions contemporains.
Ils utilisent maintenant
leur équipement ultramoderne
et leurs
années d'expérience
pour tenter d'élucider
les mystères
du Triangle des Bermudes.
Tandis que le ROV
s'enfonce dans l'Océan,
on fait une découverte
surprenante à 750 pieds.
Aucune erreur possible.
C'est un avion,
un Avenger.
- FT-87.
Quelle est la profondeur?
- 767 pieds.
Baissez un
peu la caméra.
Parfait.
- Regardez
le canot pneumatique.
- Juste derrière le...
- Je crois que c'est là.
Il devrait y avoir
une inscription dessus.
- Oui, il est à l'intérieur,
mais la porte est fermée.
- Sur l'autre Avenger,
il était à tribord.
Je me demande
s'il y en a deux.
- La verrière principale est arrachée,
mais il reste la cloison.
- On dirait que
le pilote a pu se dégager.
Et le reste
de l'équipage a dû sortir
par un trou à tribord
qu'on n'a pas encore vu.
« Ne pas se tenir sur la passerelle
pendant que l'aile se replie ».
Cette peinture
tient rudement bien.
Essayez de voir la tourelle
de la mitrailleuse.
- On devrait arriver
à pénétrer à l'intérieur.
- Il y a tellement
de trucs là-dedans
qu'on a du mal
à se frayer un chemin.
- Les caméras retransmettent
des images étonnantes.
Dans cet environnement hostile,
la pression est si forte
qu'elle écraserait
des poumons humains.
Cet Avenger
à l'allure jadis si fière,
est maintenant recouvert
d'une couche de bactéries
qui se
multiplient sur le fer,
et le cockpit est envahi
d'anémones de mer
et autres petits animaux
qui y ont élu domicile.
- C'est surprenant
à 750 pieds.
- Essayez de passer
de l'autre côté avec le ROV.
- Grâce au propulseur
et au gouvernail,
le pilote peut
manœuvrer le ROV
de façon à voir
l'avion de plus près.
- C'est la trappe d'accès
au canot pneumatique.
On dirait
qu'elle est ouverte.
- Oui.
- Vous pouvez
vous rapprocher ?
Ça veut dire
que le pilote est sorti à tribord
et a au moins
déployé le canot.
Regardez ce corail blanc
sur le canon de la mitrailleuse.
Un petit peu de poésie.
- L'équipage est impatient
d'examiner les numéros de série
pour savoir
s'il s'agit de l'escadrille 19.
- Bon, il faudrait
qu'on repère le numéro.
Il doit être
sous cette étoile-là.
- Recouvert
par cette vase.
Voyons voir
si on peut la dégager.
- Oui, si vous
mettez la soufflerie,
ça n'abîmera
pas la peinture.
- Allons-y.
Je vais aspirer l'eau et la
remplacer par de l'eau propre.
On commence
à voir le fuselage,
une série de rivets.
Vous pouvez vérifier.
Le numéro doit se trouver
juste à cet endroit.
- Le sort de l'escadrille 19
restera
donc un mystère.
Quelque part dans
ces étendues marines,
le secret sur
ce qui est arrivé
à ces cinq bombardiers
reste bien gardé
dans les profondeurs obscures
du Triangle des Bermudes.
Du moins,
pour le moment.
Le couloir de la drogue
qui relie les Bahamas à la Floride
est parcouru par
bon nombre de hors-bords.
Mais les trafiquants imprudents
sont souvent victimes
de ces eaux impitoyables.
Ils finissent ici.
Vaisseaux fantômes
échoués sur les fonds marins.
Cette région,
connue sous le nom
de Triangle des Bermudes,
couvre plus d'un million
de kilomètres carrés
d'un océan trompeur
et est traversée par l'une des voies
de navigation commerciale
les plus
pratiquées du monde.
C'est aussi l'un des hauts lieux
de la navigation de plaisance.
La conjugaison de ces deux
facteurs fait de cet endroit
l'un des plus
fréquentés de la planète.
Il n'est donc guère
surprenant que les fonds marins
du Triangle des Bermudes
soient jonchés
d'épaves de toutes sortes.
Le Deep See est tombé
sur les vestiges
d'un voilier de course élancé,
le Yankee Girl.
Ses mats
n'avaient pas de voiles.
Bizarrement elles
étaient toutes arrimées
et les écoutilles
étaient grandes ouvertes.
Pour tout bon marin,
cela indique que
quelque chose s'est passé
et que ce bateau
a fini par sombrer,
victime de
circonstances mystérieuses
dans le
Triangle des Bermudes.
Les recherches se poursuivant,
un autre bateau surgit des abysses.
Un bateau
de plaisance de Miami.
Une rapide enquête
révèle qu'il appartenait
à un homme
de Clearwater, en Floride,
qui affirme l'avoir vendu
en 1982 à Miami.
Le bateau
s'appelle le Big Mom.
La piste s'arrête là.
Les hublots et les écoutilles
ont été arrachés
par la pression
de l'air contenu dans la coque.
Le gouvernail et le servomoteur
de barre sont manquants,
peut-être à cause du choc
du bateau contre le fond.
La chaise du
capitaine est coincée
dans l'écoutille d'accès
à la salle des machines,
ce qui laisse à penser
qu'il s'est passé
quelque chose de bizarre
juste avant que
le bateau ne sombre.
L'Océan sait effacer les indices
qui pourraient expliquer
comment
ce bateau a fini ici.
Encore une disparition
dans le Triangle des Bermudes
qui restera inexpliquée.
L'un des mystères
les plus troublants
remonte à mars 1918,
lorsque l'USS Cyclopes,
un navire ravitailleur de la Navy
d'une capacité de 19 000 tonnes,
quitte la Barbade pour Baltimore.
C'est l'un des plus gros
navires de l'époque.
Son équipage
compte 309 hommes.
Et soudain, quelque part
dans le Triangle des Bermudes,
le Cyclopes disparaît.
Pendant des années,
les scientifiques ont essayé
d'expliquer la
disparition de ces bateaux
et ils ont émis
plusieurs théories fascinantes,
comme celle
des lames de fond.
Des vagues gigantesques
qui semblent venues de nulle part
et submergent un bateau
avant qu'il ait le temps de réagir.
- Il y a des lames de fond
dans les zones
baignées par le Gulf Stream.
Les principales
causes en sont avant tout
le courant et les vents,
souvent présents
lorsque des tempêtes arrivent
depuis la
côte des États-Unis,
qui rendent les vagues
bien plus grosses
qu'elles ne devraient l'être.
Il y a aussi autre chose.
Les masses d'air chaud
qu'on trouve au dessus du Gulf Stream
alimentent les tempêtes.
Si bien qu'on se retrouve avec
des creux non plus de trois mètres
mais de quatre,
cinq six mètres.
Alors quand on est
dans un petit bateau la nuit
et qu'en l'espace
d'un quart d'heure
on rencontre des creux qui
passent de trois à cinq mètres,
ça peut mal finir,
surtout si tout le monde
est en bas à dormir.
- Il y a des lames de fond
dans le Triangle des Bermudes.
Et à vrai dire,
il y un cas très intéressant
que nous venons
de finir d'étudier.
C'est une lame de fond
qui s'est propagée
jusqu'à la
côte Est de la Floride
et qui a frappé
Daytona Beach de plein fouet.
- Certaines atteignent une hauteur
évaluée à une trentaine de mètres.
Une autre théorie fait
intervenir les hydrates de méthane.
Quand du méthane s'échappe
par les fissures des fonds marins,
les bulles de gaz
remontent à la surface.
- Si un bateau se trouvait
dans l'une de ces zones
où le méthane remonte en quantité
sous forme de bulles,
on aurait un abaissement
de la densité de l'eau
de l'ordre
de 20 à 30 %.
Ce bateau
perdrait sa flottabilité.
et sombrerait très vite.
D'ailleurs il y a eu des
plateformes pétrolières off-shore
qui ont provoqué
des émissions de gaz.
Et quand ces gaz
se sont échappés,
les plateformes ont
coulé très rapidement
parce que l'eau
ne les portait plus.
Si on pouvait affirmer
que des bulles de méthane
remontent à certains endroits
du Triangle des Bermudes,
on pourrait peut-être
relier ce phénomène
à certains problèmes
qui sont apparus là-bas,
ces disparitions inexpliquées.
- Cette théorie est étayée
par des études océanographiques
qui ont établi que le sol
du Triangle des Bermudes
est l'un des plus riches
en hydrocarbures gazeux du monde.
Un bateau de ce type
qui a sombré récemment
au large de la Floride,
a été entraîné par les
puissants courants du Gulf Stream
et a traversé l'Atlantique.
Il a été retrouvé
au large des côtes anglaises.
- Regardez, il y a un cordage
attaché au bastingage.
Il va jusqu'à l'ancre
qui est sur le siège arrière.
Et il y a un projecteur.
Vous le voyez ?
- Le câble
électrique qui pend ?
- Oui, c'est un
projecteur qui pend.
Vous voyez
le câble blanc ?
- Presque au sol.
- Ça a dû
se passer de nuit.
Ce bateau a l'air
d'être là depuis assez longtemps
pour avoir sombré
à la grande époque
du trafic de drogue
via les Bahamas.
Ils ont probablement eu des
problèmes de moteur et ont coulé.
Ces bateaux ont une
ligne de flottaison très basse.
Alors quand la mer est démontée
et que le moteur tombe en panne,
ils ont vu
qu'ils étaient mal partis,
ont préparé l'ancre,
déroulé les cordages.
Ils ont dû essuyer quelques
vagues un peu trop grosses.
Ces bateaux sont
parfaits quand il fait beau,
mais quand ça se gâte,
ce n'est sans doute pas
ce qui se fait de plus sûr.
- Tour de contrôle de Miami.
Ici Piper N3994F
en route pour Nassau.
J'ai des
problèmes de moteur
et mes
instruments s'affolent.
Je sollicite un guidage radar
jusqu'à l'aéroport de Miami.
Terminé.
- Bien reçu
Piper 3994F.
La piste
neuf gauche est libre.
Contactez
la tour de contrôle
quand vous ne serez
plus qu'à huit kilomètres.
Terminé.
- Mayday, mayday.
Ici Piper N3994F.
Je perds de l'altitude,
je vais amerrir,
je dois être
à 30 kilomètres à l'Est.
- Bien reçu Piper,
ici la tour de contrôle de Miami.
On vous suit sur le radar,
on envoie les secours.
Bonne chance.
- Au fil des ans,
des centaines d'avions
de toutes les tailles
ont disparu dans
le Triangle des Bermudes.
Un pilote de ligne
dit avoir rencontré
ce qu'il appelle
un bloc d'air
à 1500 mètres
au-dessus du Gulf Stream,
qui aurait
secoué son avion
comme un fox terrier
secoue un rat
puis l'aurait envoyé
à 4500 mètres d'altitude.
Il ajoute qu'il a eu
de la chance de s'en sortir.
Il y a aussi
toutes ces histoires
d'enlèvements
par des ovnis,
de distorsion spatio temporelle,
de champs magnétiques
et autres forces
étranges et inexpliquées.
L'une de ces théories
prétend que quand
la boussole d'un avion s'affole,
c'est qu'il y a un vaisseau
spatial non identifié au-dessus.
Et que quand celui-ci
change de direction,
la boussole le suit.
Cela peut
sembler étrange,
mais n'oublions pas
que c'est Einstein
qui a compris le premier
que l'espace et le temps étaient liés.
Les scientifiques étudient
les champs de gravitation
au-dessus de la Terre.
Faut-il y voir l'explication
de toutes ces disparitions
dans le
Triangle des Bermudes ?
-Un incident étrange s'est produit
à bord du Queen Elizabeth
pendant l'une de
ses traversée de l'Atlantique.
Elle était
suivie par un avion
et cet avion,
voulant distraire les passagers,
s'est rapproché du paquebot,
a fait demi-tour puis
est passé à l'avant du bateau.
Et à ce moment-là,
pendant ce virage,
il a disparu.
Beaucoup se sont dit
qu'il était tombé dans l'Océan,
mais c'est impossible
avec tous ces gens
qui l'observaient en même temps.
Il s'est
littéralement volatilisé.
- On a eu le cas d'un Boeing B-52
superfortress de l'US Air Force
qui rentrait
des Açores aux Bermudes.
Il était à 25 000 pieds
quand l'opérateur radar
qui avait
les Bermudes sur son écran,
a remarqué que
l'avion ne se déplaçait plus.
Il a aussitôt
appelé les pilotes.
Ces derniers ont
contacté les Bermudes
qui avaient
le B-50 sur leur radar.
Personne
ne peut expliquer
pourquoi
pendant une heure,
avec quatre moteurs et
deux réacteurs à plein rendement,
cet avion
n'a pas bougé d'un pouce.
Les pilotes ont pris de l'altitude,
perdu de l'altitude,
mais rien de ce qu'ils ont tenté
n'a pu faire changer la position
de l'avion
pendant environ une heure.
Ce n'est qu'alors
qu'il a commencé
à s'éloigner
de ce champ de force.
Nul ne sait
ce que c'était.
L'avion a fini
par atterrir aux Bermudes.
Ils avaient consommé l'équivalent
de 70 minutes de carburant de plus
que ce qu'ils
consommaient habituellement
et officiellement sur les registres,
il n'y a aucune explication.
- Depuis de
nombreuses années,
des ovnis ont été signalés
dans le Triangle des Bermudes.
- Ils sont plus fréquents
au-dessus du Triangle des Bermudes
que dans
d'autres régions maritimes.
Mais on en a vu
à peu près partout sur la Terre
et particulièrement
au dessus des mers.
Je pense que
d'ici quelques années,
on saura
à quoi s'en tenir,
parce qu'ils existent.
Qu'ils soient le
reflet de quelque chose
qui s'est produit
dans le passé
ou, comme je me
le suis souvent demandé,
que ces ovnis
que nous voyons aujourd'hui
viennent
de notre propre avenir.
- L'explication peut-être
la plus étrange avancée
pour expliquer
ces disparitions,
est l'idée
que le Triangle des Bermudes
se trouverait à l'emplacement
du continent perdu de l'Atlantide.
Certains croient que
des astronautes des temps anciens
venus d'autres mondes,
se rendent
régulièrement sur l'Atlantide
et que,
de temps en temps,
ils ramènent
un humain avec eux.
- Nombreux sont ceux qui croient
que l'Atlantide se situe
dans le Triangle des Bermudes,
tout près des îles Bimini.
C'est là qu'on trouve
la mystérieuse route de Bimini.
Graham Hawkes
est allé enquêter sur place.
Ça, c'est la route Est
et cette ligne sombre là-bas,
c'est la route Ouest.
Elles sont distantes
d'une quinzaine de mètres
et font à peu près
cinq mètres de large.
On va avancer de ce côté
et jeter l'ancre au Sud de l'île.
- C'est donc une
autoroute à deux voies ?
- Oui.
- À la fin des
années 1960
on fait une découverte étonnante
au large des îles Bimini.
Une série d'énormes pierres
formant une route au fond de l'Océan.
Ces pierres,
pesant une à 10 tonnes,
semblent avoir été
disposées ainsi par l'Homme.
Preuve,
pour certains,
qu'on est bien
sur les lieux de l'Atlantide.
La légende de l'Atlantide,
vieille de plus de 11 000 ans,
évoque un empire extraordinaire
établi sur une île de l'Atlantique
qui aurait connu
un degré de civilisation
resté inégalé
dans l'Histoire.
L'Atlantide est censé
avoir été englouti
en l'espace
de quelques heures
sans laisser
aucune trace.
Il en est aussi qui croient
qu'à cet endroit,
il y a peut-être
des cristaux géants
dans les
profondeurs de la terre.
Ils seraient là
pour guider des ovnis
et pourraient donc
être la source
qui affole les
instruments de navigation
des bateaux et des avions
dans le
Triangle des Bermudes.
- On voit bien pourquoi
certains croient que ça a été fait
de la main de l'Homme.
- Ils pensent
qu'il s'agit de l'Atlantide.
Que c'est l'un des tout premiers
signes révélateurs de ce continent
et que progressivement,
on pourra voir de plus en plus
d'éléments de cette civilisation.
- C'est sûr que quand on y croit,
on voit cette route.
Certains alignements
sont troublants,
mais quand même pas
suffisamment convaincants
- C'est difficile de trancher
dans un sens ou dans un autre
et il n'y a rien qui puisse
faire pencher la balance.
Mais il y a un peu trop
d'uniformité dans cet alignement
pour qu'il soit
seulement dû à la nature.
- Beaucoup de pilotes
ont signalé que
leurs instruments
s'étaient affolés
à proximité des îles Bimini.
- Vers la fin des années 1960
et le début des années 1970,
j'assurais la navette
pour les Bahamas chaque semaine.
À 50 ou 60 kilomètres
à l'Ouest de West End,
quand je rentrais
sur le continent
et que le Soleil
était dans le bon axe,
en regardant l'Océan,
on voyait ces routes sous marines
qui formaient
des lignes parfaitement droites,
englouties depuis
des millions d'années.
Et juste à cet endroit,
pas à chaque fois,
mais assez souvent,
on constatait une forte déviation
magnétique de la boussole.
Elle s'affolait
complètement.
On volait comme ça
pendant une trentaine de kilomètres
puis la
boussole se calmait.
- J'ai entendu dire
que quand les bateaux
et les avions passent
dans le Triangle des Bermudes,
il arrive que
leurs instruments s'affolent.
D'après ce qu'on en sait,
il n'y a aucune raison
pour qu'ils s'affolent
à cause d'un champ magnétique.
En effet, si un avion ou
un bateau essuie des turbulences,
sa boussole marque
normalement une oscillation.
Or, avec toutes les mesures
du champ magnétique qu'on a faites,
on n'a jamais pu mettre
en évidence ce phénomène.
Et pourtant, on en a
vraiment fait beaucoup
dans le Triangle
des Bermudes et ailleurs.
- On a souvent constaté
que les expériences des aviateurs
étaient en contradiction
avec la réalité scientifique.
Les Hommes du Deep See
font une découverte extraordinaire.
On envoie le ROV pour examiner
l'intérieur d'un petit avion.
- Restez où vous êtes
jusqu'à ce que ça se dégage.
- Vous allez droit dessus.
- Ça y est,
je l'ai à l'écran.
Ça fait
un moment qu'il est là.
Regardez.
Le toit commence à s'affaisser.
Voyons ça de plus près.
Voici le numéro,
N3647Q.
On dirait que les deux portes
sont verrouillées.
Il n'y a que
ces hublots d'arrachés.
- Oui, la partie
supérieure est partie.
Je me demande si ça s'est cassé
quand l'avion a heurté le fond.
- Ces avions ont un train
d'atterrissage fixe,
ce qui ne convient sans doute
pas bien à un amerrissage.
Au moindre choc,
ça lâche.
- Pour examiner
l'intérieur du cockpit
dans l'espoir d'y trouver
des objets de valeur
ou des restes humains,
on décide d'utiliser le ROV
pour tenter de pénétrer
dans l'avion
par l'arrière.
- À ce que j'en vois par le hublot,
il semble qu'heureusement
il n'y ait personne là-dedans.
Ça a l'air vide.
- C'est bizarre que toutes les
portes du cockpit soient fermées.
Après un amerrissage forcé,
quand on
s'extirpe de l'avion,
on ne referme pas
la porte derrière soi, si ?
- Voilà, tout en douceur.
- On va peut être devoir
l'enfoncer, doucement.
- Allez, on y va.
Elle est efficace
cette barre.
Ça y est
les gonds ont sauté.
C'est vraiment
pas construit en dur.
On voit la
structure en nid d'abeilles.
Ce côté
s'ouvre tout seul.
- Vous avez
réussi à ouvrir ?
- Sous la poussée du ROV,
la porte commence à s'effriter,
ce qui permet au submersible
d'avoir une image nette
de l'intérieur de l'avion.
- L'un de ces strapontins.
Regardez toute
cette saleté, quel bazar.
- Il n'y a rien du tout,
ni objets de valeur,
ni cargaison mystérieuse.
Les hommes
du Deep See
décident
d'essayer d'ouvrir
les portes scellées
du compartiment passager.
- On dirait que tout ce qu'il y a
dans le cockpit,
c'est cette
espèce de cartable.
Il est ouvert.
- C'est peut-être
une visière.
- Oui,
on dirait une visière.
Je crois
que la tache est tombée.
C'est complètement
vide là-dedans.
C'est plein de détritus.
Le toit continue
de se désagréger.
Et le tableau de bord,
il y a des clés dessus ?
Des clés de contact ?
Mais il n'y a pas
de clés sur ces avions.
- Quand on amerrit
en catastrophe,
vous pensez vraiment
qu'on enlève les clés ?
J'espère que
ces types s'en sont sortis,
mais on n'en sait rien.
- On vérifiera
dans les archives.
- Cet avion, un Piper,
avait été volé il y a quinze ans
sur l'aéroport
de Pompano Beach.
On ignorait
ce qu'il était devenu.
La police pensait
que l'avion avait été volé
et servait
à passer de la drogue.
Mais rien n'indique comment
le pilote ou les passagers éventuels
auraient pu s'en sortir.
Dans le Triangle des Bermudes,
une belle journée
peut très vite
tourner au cauchemar.
- Avis de tempête.
Des vents violents
provoqueront des orages forts,
à très forts.
Il est recommandé
à tous les bateaux
d'accoster immédiatement
sur le rivage le plus proche.
- Les marinas de Floride
abritent des milliers de bateaux.
Chaque jour,
ils sont un nombre indéterminé
à s'aventurer dans les eaux
du Triangle des Bermudes.
Et parfois,
ils ne reviennent pas.
L'une des histoires
les plus connues
de ces dernières années
est celle d'un
restaurateur célèbre de Floride,
Charlie Muer, qui partit avec
sa femme et un couple d'amis
faire une croisière
entre les Bahamas et la Floride.
Son voilier
de douze mètres
portait le nom de sa chaîne
de restaurants, Charlie's Crab.
Muer qui passait
pour un excellent marin,
essuya une violente tempête
et son bateau disparut.
L'US Air Force et les garde côtes
entamèrent des recherches.
- Au lever du jour,
les avions décollent.
Cette tempête
d'une violence inattendue
est déjà surnommée
la tempête du siècle,
avec des vents
de plus de 100 kilomètres/ heure
et des creux
de six à neuf mètres.
D'après les garde côtes,
c'est typique
du Triangle des Bermudes
et ça n'a rien à voir avec
des distorsions de l'espace,
des ovnis ou des rayons laser
venus de l'Atlantide.
- On pense qu'ils étaient
à une cinquantaine de kilomètres
de la côte américaine,
du côté
de West Palm Beach,
quand une tempête
épouvantable s'est déclenchée.
Ça a été la tempête
du siècle, en mars 1993,
et une douzaine de bateaux
ont sombré ce jour-là
au large de la Floride.
Dix bateaux de pêche,
un autre voilier
et un cargo de 70 mètres
ont disparu,
pour la plupart au large
de la côte Ouest de la Floride.
On suppose que le Charlie's Crab
a été pris dans la tempête
et que c'est ainsi
qu'il a disparu.
- Quand les rapports
sur la gravité de la tempête
arrivent
au QG des garde côtes,
il devient évident
que le Charlie's Crab
n'est pas le seul
bateau en détresse.
Des SOS retentissent
dans toute la péninsule de Floride.
Dans cette
séquence dramatique,
une famille embarquée sur
un voilier sera finalement sauvée.
La violence des vents
et les énormes creux
rendent cet exercice de sauvetage
périlleux pour tout le monde.
À la fin de la journée,
162 personnes
auront été arrachées
par les gardes côtes aux flots
meurtriers de l'Atlantique
et du golfe du Mexique.
Mais aucune trace
du Charlie's Crab.
- On a passé au crible
plus de 280 000 kilomètres carrés
entre les Bahamas et Miami
et jusqu'à la côte
de Caroline du Nord.
On a fouillé une zone plus grande
que les États de Floride
et de Caroline
du Sud réunis, en vain.
Le seul indice qu'on ait
sur l'endroit
où ils peuvent avoir disparu
c'est un appel fait pendant la tempête
sur un téléphone cellulaire
à 4h30 du matin,
le samedi 13 mars.
- Alors Ken, cet appel téléphonique,
ça donne quelque chose.
- Ça peut nous aider
car on sait que tôt le matin,
il y a eu un appel de détresse,
un SOS lancé par le Charlie's Crab
qui a été reçu
par la police de Lantana.
On a identifié les trois zones
cellulaires les plus proches
de la source de cet appel.
Avec cette information
et l'information que vous avez,
on pourrait tenter de déterminer
l'endroit où le bateau a pu sombrer.
- Ça collerait avec l'idée
qu'il a chaviré très vite,
que son antenne VHF
est tombée à l'eau
et qu'il a dû utiliser
son téléphone cellulaire
pour l'appel de détresse.
Si on met tout ça bout à bout
et si c'est bien ça,
alors il doit
se trouver par là.
- L'équipe se fait également aider
par une femme skipper
qui travaillait
pour Charlie Muer.
- Qu'est-il arrivé
au Charlie's Crab ?
- Je pense que
le bateau a coulé très vite.
Il a sans doute chaviré.
Cette tempête était
d'une violence inouïe
et elle est arrivée très vite.
Et à l'endroit où
le bateau était censé se trouver
au début du Gulf Stream,
les vagues peuvent atteindre
une hauteur énorme.
Quelqu'un qui se retrouve
dans une telle situation
peut très vite
avoir de gros problèmes.
- Au début des recherches,
le sonar indique
la présence d'un gros bateau.
Le Deep See vire de bord,
pour aller s'en assurer,
mais le sonar semble brouillé
par la proximité de l'épave.
Les chercheurs envoient le ROV
pour constater l'étendue des dégâts
et examiner ce qu'ils espèrent
être le Charlie's Crab.
- Vous devriez
l'avoir à l'écran.
- Le voilà.
Qu'il est moche.
C'est un gros chalutier
ou quelque chose comme ça.
- Il y a une immatriculation.
- On peut
s'approcher de l'arrière ?
- Vous arrivez à lire ?
Corpus ?
- Corpus Christi, Texas.
- Corpus Christi.
- C'est un gros chalutier,
il doit faire dans les
35 mètres de long.
Vous voyez
ce motif peint sur la proue,
ces bandes jaunes ?
- Ils viennent de découvrir
un gros bateau de pêche
appartenant à un Texan.
Celui-ci dit que son bateau
rentrait au Texas
quand il fut pris
dans une tempête soudaine.
Mais l'examen du bateau
révèle que les portants
qui tiennent les filets de pêche
sont bloqués en position verticale,
position qui rend
le bateau instable
et ne peut que
favoriser le chavirement.
Très coûteux et quasi neuf
au moment de son naufrage,
le Michael Jay
portait le nom
du plus jeune fils
de son propriétaire.
Non seulement le Deep See
n'avait pas réussi
à retrouver ce qu'il cherchait,
l'épave du Charlie's Crab,
mais au cours des recherches,
le Triangle des Bermudes
lui avait
joué un sale tour
en confisquant son précieux
sonar à balayage latéral,
pris dans un câble
de cette épave
couverte de rouille.
La situation était grave.
- C'est ça qu'on a heurté
à une douzaine de mètres du pont.
C'est ça qui nous coince.
Ce câble pend
le long de la coque.
Peut-être qu'on pourrait
le couper à ce niveau-là.
On pourrait le coincer,
le prendre en
sandwich contre la coque
et cogner dessus
jusqu'à ce qu'il lâche.
- On dirait
qu'il n'y a plus de hublots.
Ça indique peut-être
qu'il a été sabordé.
- Quel bazar.
- Il y a du matériel
électronique là-dedans.
Il n'a donc
pas été sabordé.
Regardez-là, il y a
un radar et du matériel.
On ne saborderait
pas un bateau
avec du matériel
électronique à bord.
- Le Michael Jay
a donc été retrouvé.
Son propriétaire
nous informe
que les marins
ont survécu au naufrage.
Mais le Charlie's Crab
reste prisonnier
du Triangle des Bermudes.
Il y a 500 ans,
Christophe Colomb remarquait déjà
qu'il se passait
des choses bizarres ici.
Et depuis, cette zone
reste baignée de mystères.
Au fil des ans,
la légende n'a fait que s'amplifier.
Pourtant, vous l'avez vu,
la plupart de ces mystères
ont pu être expliqués.
Les scientifiques en
savent bien plus aujourd'hui
sur les profondeurs,
la météo, les lames de fond
et autres phénomènes,
qu'il y a 20 ou 30 ans.
Mais même aujourd'hui,
l'océanographie en est encore
à ses premiers
balbutiements.
- Il reste sûrement
des découvertes fondamentales
à faire dans les océans.
Par exemple dans les zones
sur lesquelles nous travaillons ici,
dans le
Triangle des Bermudes,
on a trouvé des trous
dans la structure du sol.
Des trous
de 100 mètres de diamètre.
Ils font sans doute partie
d'un système très ancien.
Si ces trous ont pu
rester inconnus jusqu'en 1994,
alors qu'ils sont à dix kilomètres
à peine au large de Miami,
nous n'avons
aucune idée
de ce que nous avons encore
à découvrir dans les profondeurs.
- Même si les connaissances
scientifiques actuelles
nous laissent à penser
que le Triangle des Bermudes
est un endroit
où il ne se passe rien d'anormal,
je ne peux pas affirmer
avec une certitude absolue
qu'il n'y a pas là-bas
quelque chose
qu'on découvrira un jour
et qui changera notre vision
scientifique de cette zone.
- En attendant,
les théories sur les extraterrestres
continueront de nous fasciner
et de nous intriguer.
Et qui sait, ce n'est pas non plus
complètement impossible.
Tout ce
qu'on peut dire,
c'est qu'il y aura toujours
un Triangle des Bermudes.